I've got a crazy idea  okay she wants to live with you your  hair quite know how you'll take this but  well I've got to get it off my chin I  wanted to see you okay I'm telling you  many times I've saw here and just  imagine G sitting right there do I track  I'll tell my wife  it's over and Italian my god this is  great news  the great news we have a paint a real  one  [Music]  I can't stop thinking about you  any chance we can find some time during  the day are you thing coming up you are  so close finally breaking free no but I  can't do it and I never thought I feel  this right through my eye I've hardly  seen you asleep  I've been overly occupied so you're  screwing your wife now as if Mary yeah  well you fell asleep on me that's what  happened here powered my coffee to tell  her mom everybody knows I'm an idiot all  right took that number [ __ ] back if you  could kissing you  [Music]  [Applause]  oh hey pizza not today Barry thanks I  got a scoop  [Music]  you